c'est pas voilà c'est pas parce qu'on
s'y intéresse pas c'est qu'il ya 23 et
entre 23 26% d'intentions de vote pour
le président mais les 13% d'eric zemmour
c'est quand même et non que donc comment
le prône enfin ce qui est intéressant si
vous voulez encore une fois c'est la
dynamique c'est la progression à
s'arrêter à cinq ou six il a il a connu
plusieurs paliers l'a connu 8 puis 11 et
maintenant 13 donc effectivement il faut
juger des choses en dynamique de moyenne
en mode ce qu'il faut c'est la question
qu'on veut que tout le monde voie verte
ici on voit bien qui siphonnent le rnd
se donne pas le président wim et adresse
que je veux dire c'est qu'en fait dans
le dans le camp national c'est à dire
tous les électeurs du rassemblement
national de debout la france les
sympathisants d'eric zemmour que la
seule question qui vaille c'est au
second tour est ce qu'on a envie de voir
un débat macro le pen ou est ce qu'on a
envie de voir un débat macron zemmour où
vous avez envie d'en bas ben moi j'ai
envie de voir macro zemmour pasaia corps
de marine le pen c'est fini le ballon à
messi bah si les baduy mafia nous ils
viennent nous regardent ce soir a dit
vraiment je remets siens nami tricard
humaniste ricard totalement non pas du
tout moi vous savez je n'ai jamais eu de
voila j'ai quitté le rassemblement
national au moment où parce que eric
zemmour est un ami pas marine le pen je
n'ai pas les mêmes liens d'amitié avec
marine le pen et d'amour de quoi tout à
fait honnête oui c'est dans le grand est
ce que vous allez rejoindre eric zemmour
s'il fait campagne
pour l'instant si voulez moi je suis
chef sur les médias est un peu tôt mais
tu peux partir
alors quel genre qui permet rapidement
qu'ils pensaient soutenir énorme et bien
sûr nation gens non mais dites dit la
vérité mais franchement là sérieusement
non pas là on rigole pas vous vous allez
vous allez suivre et rayonnant genre
écouter général sans aide pour l'instant
j'en sais rien on j'y suis je me suis
malheureusement plus de la générale et
celle un peu plus âgées mais mais voilà
je sais je sais pas je sais pas ce que
je vais faire honnêtement sincèrement je
sais pas ce que le faire bien jal a jugé
utile et nous allons y aller de son
ministre de l'intérieur j'ai eu un
engagement politique de quatre années où
j'étais dans la politique opérationnelle
je fais des fédérations je suis à
l'arrière en compte gmail de militants
des adhérents etc j'ai envie de faire un
de faire maintenant un peu autre chose
que je suis en train de faire ce que
j'aime bien ce que je suis en train de
faire pour l'instant dans un visage à
base de lait c'est avait envie nous
avons envie de soutenir eric zemmour
s'agit de soutenir six présents mais je
soutiendrai je sais pas c'est qui votre
candidat préféré là mais j'ai pas et par
jean-luc mélenchon non c'est bon
mais j'espère qu'ils écoutent où je suis
je suis
les journalistes du service public non
mais sans risque notre ère la nation et
vous vous avez changé ah bon franchement
vous avez plus de couilles un nom mais
giuly à
la télé vous a changé en tout cas du
point de vue anatomique elles sont
toujours là je suis content de savoir
mais en tout cas au moins de vue moral
elles sont plus là non mais morale qu'on
voit pas dit la vérité est qu'on est ici
on dirait que zemmour on se dit les
choses en plus à l'heure où je vous
parle je n'en suis pas encore convaincu
parce que j'ai entamé un virage dans ma
carrière et je me dois le dire la nuit
voilà pourquoi le virage 3 toute l'année
risque grandit négocier un virage
négocié un virage tennis je
voulais voilà vous soutenez personnes je
soutiens personne je vous dis je suis
aussi neutre que les gens avaient du
service public
impartiale commémorons la sortie de x ça
c'est pas grave pour la sortie de pro
d2 2e ce que je retiens on rigole savent
rajon missia ça va bon et ça vous a fait
de la peine pour marine le pen ce
sondage là
les gens si vous a fait de la paix
détendez vous dit rien vous savez en
politique c'est le peuple et les gens
qui décident donc les gens et fait tout
le monde peut se présenter tout le monde
peut aller au devant des français et
quand on va au devant des français soit
il ya quelque chose qui se passe je
pense que c'est ce qui compte c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer avec eric
zemmour soit il ya quelque chose qui ne
se passe pas ou qui ne se passe plus à
allah et il a répondu à la question
mais ça c'est le père fouras